- Oh, bartender, you forgot my drink.
It's okay, I can wait.
Oh my gosh, I'm such a Kanye right now.
Give me my damn drink.
I'm so bad!
- You are so bad. You are such a Kanye.
Like honestly, you're a Kanye.
Okay, okay, okay, if I were one of the
greatest rappers of our generation,
which one would I be?
- You are such a Biggie!
- I know, I know, I'm such a Biggie!--
- Such a Biggie.
- How many times a day do I say,
"It was all a dream"?
- Too many.
- Betty.
- I'm gonna go out on a limb,
and you may disagree with me,
but I think I am such a--
- Tupac!
I mean, I constantly wanna pop
caps in people's asses.
- Oh my god!
- Who am I? Who am I? I'm Tupac.
- From head to toe, from head to toe.
- Bartender, I'm still waiting.
- Okay, guys, do me, do me.
- Okay.
- This should be fun.
- On the count of three,
altogether now okay.
One, two, three.
- Drake!
- Jay Z! What?
- Um, Justin. You're not Jay Z.
- Such a Drake.
- I totally am a Jay Z.
How dare you call me a Drake?
I drop classics daily at
the office and at home.
- Yeah, but you're just
so emotional about it?
I mean, it's still good, but so emotional!
- Um, excuse me.
- Yeah.
- Excuse me.
- Excuse me, but last
week I gave a presentation
that Abe himself deemed, and I quote,
"was like the blueprint."
Now how is that not Jay Z?
- Honey, you included an entire slideshow
called "How to Love
Yourself Better" on YouTube,
and that is so Drake.
- That's so Drake.
- Bartender, I'm still
waiting for my drink.
Thank you very much.
- Guys.
- What?
- Guys, let's not forget that I
dated the hottest chick in the game,
Lorraine from finance, for a year.
Now, how is that not Jay-Z?
- Yeah, but when you broke up,
you cried for like two
whole business days,
then wrote a whole newsletter about it.
That is so Drake.
- So Drake.
- I am not Drake!
The fact that you guys
are even calling me Drake is hurtful.
I don't know if we can be friends anymore.
No new friends.
I started from the
bottom and now I'm here.
- You know what, I'm just
going to get my own drink.
- Well just hold on! Just hold on.
We're going home anyway.
- Okay, now we're going home.
- Yeah.
- Could he be anymore Drake?
- He's the biggest Drake.
This has to be (mumbles).
- I know.
- It has to be his (mumbles).
- He just needs to accept it.
- Oh my god. I am such a Drake.
- Honey!
(friends cheer)
- You are such a Drake!
- Hey, bartender! It's been 15 minutes!
How long does it take
to make a Cosmo, gosh!
I am such a Kanye!
(friends laugh)
- You are such a Kanye!
- Well, where's his (explicit) drink?!
- Seriously!
Subscribe for more wonderful things
Music: Today is Tomorrow/Put Your Hands Up
Warner/Chappell Production Music
True Love Stories, Unknown Number
For even more wonderful things
subscribe to BuzzFeed Blue